JUDY WOODRUFF: Now the story
of a young man teaching
math to the world.
NewsHour correspondent
Spencer Michels reports.
SALMAN KHAN: So this is
a quadratic equation,
essentially.
We're trying to
find the zeros of--
SPENCER MICHELS: This
disembodied voice
is heard every day by tens
of thousands of students
struggling with math, both in
the US and around the world.
33-year-old Salman Khan
recently quit his job
as a hedge fund analyst
to devote himself
to an unpaid job teaching
math on the internet.
SALMAN KHAN: Welcome to the
presentation on basic addition.
These are cancers,
or cancer cells.
There's the investors and the
mortgage-backed securities--
SPENCER MICHELS: He has
posted 1,200 lessons
on YouTube, which appear
on an electronic blackboard
and range in subject
from basic addition
and advanced calculus
to science and finance.
And they are free.
SALMAN KHAN: Introduction
to trigonometry
is where I teach people
about the trig functions.
This is one of the
more popular videos.
This has 179,000 views.
And this is just what sine,
cosine, and tangent are.
SPENCER MICHELS: Kahn lives
in California's Silicon Valley
with his wife, a rheumatologist
in training at Stanford,
and their new baby.
He got the idea for Khan
Academy four years ago
when he taught a
young cousin how
to convert kilograms to grams.
Many American students
have trouble with math,
and studies show they lag behind
their counterparts in Asia
and Europe in both
math and science.
With Khan's help, his
cousin got good at math,
and he eventually
had a new career
tapping into anxieties
around the world.
Now he records his lessons
from a converted closet
in the back of his bedroom.
He never goes on camera.
SALMAN KHAN: It kind of feels
like the voice in their head.
You're looking at it.
It kind of feels like someone's
over your shoulder talking
in your ear, as
opposed to someone
at a blackboard that's
distant from you.
SPENCER MICHELS: Although
he is not the first person
to teach on the internet,
his simple operation
has attracted more eyeballs
than most universities' sites.
For Khan, teaching math
and science and finance
is just the beginning.
He's ready to expand
his YouTube site
to include whatever
strikes his fancy.
SALMAN KHAN: I want
to do everything.
I want to do history.
I want to do grammar.
I want to do literally
every subject.
SPENCER MICHELS: So far,
except for a little advertising
revenue, he is donating
his time and equipment.
It's a one-man
operation, but it's
gotten so big he expects
to start soliciting
outside support to keep
his academy growing.